[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je me suis demandé si j'allais pouvoir
continuer à vivre en Nouvelle-Zélande si
on ne gagnait pas ce match
j'ai rite d'une équipe championne du
monde en 2001 on est en 2016 j'ai
toujours rien gagné
[Musique]
et je sais à ce moment-là si un nouvel
échec ça sera le dernier pour moi
à réfléchir aux décisions à prendre
[Musique]
il fallait gagner il fallait absolument
la gagner cette course
s'il gagne pas c'est fini l'histoire à
s'arrête je fais 2e avec mon eau douce
et terminé
[Musique]
de départ d'une finale olympique
seul le résultat conquérant
[Musique]
la vérité c'est qu'à ce moment là
c'était difficile de ne rien dire la
situation était tellement tendue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les grands champions c'est des gens à
part et les grands entraîneurs c'est la
même chose c'est des gens qui ont un
truc en plus qui sont pas comme les
autres
la route vers les sommets et se met en
bus pour préparez-vous
le succès ne va pas arriver facilement
encore une fois n'aie pas peur
une chose que tu sais c'est que si tu
travailles pas tu vas pas réussir c'est
sûr si tu travailles tu es pas sûr de
réussir
[Musique]
400 bien nager
on part dans la rouge en haut ben la
rouge
[Applaudissements]
j'ai 36 heures par jour pendant 11 mois
c'est là que tu vas prendre ton pied
moi ce qui m'intéressait bien sûr
c'était de gagner des titres mais c'est
après c'est l'entraînement tu vois
trouver les solutions
les mecs les faire se dépasser leur
faire faire des choses que pour ces même
pas qui pouvaient faire donc c'est ce
qui me plaît quoi 25 50 75 100 m 100
mètres 75 50 25 d'accord bon allez on y
va premier 25 en place et
[Applaudissements]
8 7
8 40 coups de bras allez comme ça
Marie 8 tendu les coups de bras moins de
je fais 45 45 essaye de faire une 35 en
jambes 4 fois
un peu plus vite allez
chronométrer
qui sont pas bien et à partir de là bon
j'adapte le travail que je vais faire
les trois dernières allez on s'accroche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je me rappelle quand j'étais jeune je
joue au foot avec les copains dans la
cité en bas c'était moi le capitaine de
l'équipe quoi tu diriges quoi tu vois je
me mettais toujours avec l'équipe la
plus faible pour pouvoir faire l'exploit
tu vois et puis voilà j'aimais bien
motivé les mecs et bon c'est entre
gamins en bas de la cité on jouait voilà
quoi
je savais ce que je voulais je voulais
entraîner je voulais devenir entraîneur
j'ai entraîné en natation mais j'irai
faire un autre sport ça aurait été la
même chose
[Musique]
je suis entraîneur principal de l'équipe
nationale de gymnastique depuis 1993
tu dois obtenir des résultats
exceptionnels dans toutes les grandes
compétitions
[Musique]
les entraîneurs nationaux vont dans les
écoles en province pour repérer les
jeunes talents
[Musique]
ils viennent suivre leur formation ici
ce que je regarde en priorité c'est la
capacité d'assimilation des enfants
parce qu'en gymnastique il y a une
énorme quantité de mouvement différent
et il faut pouvoir apprendre chacun en
très peu de temps
ils peuvent supporter de grandes
quantités de travail puis ils pourront
atteindre un haut niveau
[Musique]
en parallèle de l'apprentissage
technique on doit aussi les former sur
le plan mental
nous avons donc mis en place les cycles
de tests réguliers
à ne pas commettre d'erreurs sous la
pression en vue des grandes compétitions
internationales
[Applaudissements]
se fait donc depuis tout petit
progressivement
dans l'équipe nationale il existe encore
beaucoup d'erreurs dans l'exécution de
figures simples
à partir d'aujourd'hui le 2 avril
après-midi à 16h40 plus aucun détail ne
doit être négligé
il est encore temps
vous pouvez disposer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ses enfants sont encore jeunes et
innocents ils sont moins exposés aux
influences extérieures que les autres
enfants de leur âge mais ils doivent
rester concentrés sur leur travail
[Musique]
la course n'est pas juste une activité
dans laquelle tu te lances comme ça
c'est un style de vie ça fait partie de
toi
[Musique]
le visage les épaules
même le son le rythme
j'en ai pas besoin j'ai comme une sorte
de chronomètre dans ma tête
[Applaudissements]
au dernier Jeux Olympiques de Londres
venus d'ici
c'est un peu la Mecque de l'athlétisme
tous les athlètes cagnan viennent d'un
milieu rural et paysans
[Applaudissements]
mais ils ont cette état d'esprit cette
force de caractère qui convient
parfaitement pour devenir athlète de
très haut niveau
vous sentez bien prêt pour la
compétition
même si je vous demandais de faire un
autre 400 mètres vous pourriez le faire
et vous le feriez en 57 ou 58 secondes
mais j'ai pas besoin de le voir je sais
que c'est là je sais que c'est en vous
j'ai pas besoin de voir ce 400 mètres
gardez-le pour le dernier tour du 10000
ou du 5000 m c'est comme ça qu'il faut
faire
je ne me considère pas comme un
entraîneur dur
j'essaie d'avoir une relation amicale de
professeur à élève
ainsi ils n'ont plus peur de toi mais te
respectes
[Musique]
et puis d'un autre côté il faut que
cette chaleur humaine il faut que c'est
ce lien il faut qu'il y ait un truc qui
voilà il y a un courant qui passe et ça
c'est obligatoire si tu es toujours
strict machin et à côté de ça tu es
froid comme je sais pas quoi ça passe
pas
vrai pas fait ce que je demande
bon ça c'était le premier travail
[Rires]
ça va mieux là
la première chose que je disais à
Raphaël quand il arrivait sur le cours
c'était soit de bonne humeur
car c'est impossible de bien s'entraîner
si tu fais la tête
arrive un moment où il faut que le gosse
comprenne qu'on est plus en train de
jouer désormais on s'entraide
quand tu es entraîneur des All Blacks tu
demandes beaucoup d'investissements aux
joueurs
pragmatique pour faire le boulot et le
faire bien
[Musique]
c'était à moi de les guider
le travail à l'entraînement doit être un
plaisir la vie ce n'est pas seulement
s'amuser c'est aussi prendre du plaisir
dans l'effort
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le plaisir c'est la gagne je te le dis
c'était de gagner des courses tu te
lèves tous les matins pour ça c'est ton
truc
je me suis toujours donné des objectifs
quand j'ai commencé à entraîner j'ai
fait une liste et un de mes buts était
de devenir entraîneur des All Blacks ça
paraît un peu arrogant non
j'avais toujours voulu prouver que elle
se parle en bien en vivant bien ensemble
en se faisant confiance en se respectant
on pouvait arriver à des résultats
exceptionnels
ce type de mouvement difficile c'est ce
qu'il faut réussir pour espérer être
champion
j'ai toujours entraîné avec un objectif
très clair atteindre le plus haut niveau
parce que je veux avoir ce rêve je veux
avoir cette motivation
[Applaudissements]
ma première émotion provient d'un bon
touché de balle un mouvement bien
exécuté avec ce bruit
c'est la première émotion que j'ai
toujours recherché
[Applaudissements]
j'ai commencé à entraîner au club de
tennis de notre village à Manacor le
jour où Raphaël est venu pour la
première fois il était avec son père
il devait avoir 3 ans je lui ai lancé la
balle et il l'a frappé à demain
ça m'a surpris qu'il le fasse si bien du
coup j'ai essayé de le faire jouer
davantage mais à l'époque il préférait
le football
j'ai donc attendu un peu et vers 4 ans
il a commencé à jouer régulièrement
c'était uniquement pour le jeu
l'amusement
[Musique]
le problème c'est que Raphaël a appris
très rapidement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un bon joueur
on a donc commencé à s'entraîner
sérieusement
la première fois que Raphaël a remporté
le championnat d'Espagne à 11 ans j'ai
demandé à la Fédération espagnole de
m'envoyer la liste des 20 derniers
champions dans cette catégorie
j'ai lu chacun des Noirs
champion d'Espagne comme toi tu en as
entendu parler
champion d'Espagne comme toi après il y
avait Alex coregger oui celui-là on le
connaît
et parmi les 25 il y en avait pas plus
de 5 qui par la suite sont devenus de
bons joueurs voilà c'est ça la
probabilité que tu as de devenir bon 20
ou 25%
ça dépend de toi que tu sois sur cette
liste sur celle-là
[Musique]
pour moi le souci a toujours été de
forger son caractère je voulais qu'il
garde un point d'insatisfaction dans ce
qu'il faisait afin qu'il continue à
progresser et avancer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je n'entraîne pas pour gagner de
l'argent
c'est le rêve de ma vie
j'aime m'occuper des autres
sûrement parce que ça me fait du bien à
moi tout simplement parce que je me
nourris de cette relation avec les
autres j'aime partager
le résultat pour moi devait être associé
à une forme presque philosophique que je
voulais donner à mon engagement dans le
sport
c'est vrai que j'avais le sentiment
quand même que dans mon dos les gens des
canés un peu elle est gentil lui avait
ses grandes idées mais il y arrivera
jamais
j'ai rite d'une équipe champion du monde
en 2001 on est en 2016 j'ai toujours
rien gagné
viennent de perdre les Jeux Olympiques
d'Athènes et on aborde le championnat du
monde suivant Simon après et on est à
deux doigts de se faire éliminer au
premier tour
et je sais à ce moment là si un nouvel
échec ça sera le dernier pour moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a un moment de rupture pour moi
tu te dis mais c'est maintenant qu'il va
falloir aller au bout des choses et
véritablement mettre en œuvre ce qui de
nourrit est habite
les joueurs je les ai presque provoqué
d'une certaine façon en leur disant
écoutez plutôt que d'attendre dans la
fin des compétitions pour lire dans des
interviews que vous donnez et il aurait
fallu en aurait dû il aurait mieux valu
si vous savez ce qu'il faut faire
n'attendez pas la fin de la compétition
pour nous le dire quand même donc on met
tout en commun on construit ce qui nous
paraît être le projet le plus adapté à
nous
et puis à partir de là on va le mettre
en œuvre mais non c'est parti
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les gens ont commencé à apporter les
éléments de transformation du jeu des
éléments sur la vie de l'équipe
le niveau d'engagement le niveau
d'investissement le niveau de
détermination n'a rien de comparable
chez des gens qui ont le sentiment de
participer à une aventure qu'ils ont
choisi
[Musique]
à partir du moment où ce projet est le
vôtre et que vous l'avez construit avec
les autres au moment où ce projet est en
délicatesse qu'est-ce que vous allez
faire vous allez vous fédérer et vous
allez tout mettre en oeuvre à ce
moment-là pour que ça n'échappe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aurait pas eu de résultats et on
construit l'équipe à partir du potentiel
de nos joueurs et du potentiel cette
équipe de France elle en avait beaucoup
mais je crois qu'elle a été capable en
plus de créer une espèce de force
collective qui souvent a fait la
différence avec nos meilleurs
adversaires
[Musique]
j'ai mis très longtemps avant de
vraiment me connaître je savais qui
j'étais dans le miroir je connaissais ce
gars-là mais je ne savais pas encore ce
que je devais faire pour obtenir le
meilleur de moi-même
les gars pareils
[Musique]
l'équipe des blancs vous serez les
tigres et les types vertes les lions
c'est moi l'arbitre vous avez trois
minutes trois minutes pour marquer le
plus d'essai possible c'est parti
[Musique]
au départ j'étais professeur de sport
j'étais déjà passionné de rugby
en rugby comme dans tous les sports être
entraîneur c'est d'abord être un
éducateur donc tu essayes d'aider le
jeûne à devenir non seulement un
meilleur athlète mais aussi une
meilleure personne
ça va de pair
S
mais je n'étais pas assez bon c'est
sûrement ce qui a fait que je suis
devenu entraîneur avec l'envie de
coacher les tous meilleurs
alors comment on s'améliore
vous devez vous replacer
pour recevoir la balle OK
[Musique]
un jeune entraîneur j'étais très
autoritaire je leur disais quoi faire et
j'attendais d'eux qu'il fasse ce que je
leur avais demandé
le ho black je suis passé à une forme
d'entraînement par consensus
tu dois faire en sorte que les joueurs
se sentent propriétaires responsables de
la direction de l'équipe
les joueurs et les entraîneurs ne
doivent faire qu'un afin de faire
avancer ensemble cette équipe de rugby
ça prend du temps ça demande de la
patience mais si tu ne faisais pas ça tu
étais mort
tu étais fini en tant qu'entraîneur
entraîner notre pays est très très
particulier et je l'ai pris comme un
grand privilège
bonjour rugby en Nouvelle-Zélande depuis
115 ans ça fait partie de notre identité
[Musique]
les joueurs portent le maillot noir
c'est le moment pour eux de perpétuer
cet héritage et d'entrer dans l'histoire
et en tant qu'entraîneur des All Blacks
tu dois aussi poursuivre cette histoire
et ça signifie gagner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on avait un dicton chez les All Blacks
qui disait être meilleur ne s'arrête
jamais
je peux toujours m'améliorer et si tout
le monde s'améliore alors l'équipe sera
meilleure on pourrait même être champion
du monde qui sait
[Musique]
tu as une vision du jeu et tu dois la
transmettre aux joueurs qui vont
l'exprimer sur le terrain
tout en tenant compte de la tradition et
de l'histoire du club
ce n'est pas la même chose d'entraîner
le Real Madrid
le PSG ou Chelsea
[Musique]
imposer son jeu
restez soudés Unis
[Musique]
parce qu'au final chacun a ses
motivations individuelles marquez des
buts
[Musique]
aussi l'entraîneur doit toujours se
soucier de la motivation collective de
l'équipe
convaincre les joueurs de mettre leurs
qualités au service des autres et du jeu
que ton partenaire et ton meilleur ami
sur le terrain
et qu'avec un peu de sacrifice de la
part de chacun un peu d'altruisme on
peut réussir à créer une bonne alchimie
dans le jeu de l'équipe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
établir des règles de autorité parce que
je suis le coach ça ne me plaît pas j'ai
m'établir des règles avec lesquelles les
joueurs sont à l'aise et qu'ils soient
convaincus que ces règles sont justes
que tu abuses de ton autorité c'est déjà
qu'il y a un problème
je préfère avoir un rapport sincère avec
les joueurs
ce n'est pas parce que je suis
l'entraîneur que j'ai un statut plus
élevé
[Musique]
la clé du succès d'un entraîneur est
dans la relation qu'il entretient avec
ses joueurs
[Musique]
tu commences avec un nouveau groupe tu
deviens un nouveau coach j'oublie tous
ceux qui me sont passés entre les mains
c'est cela qui vont me faire grandir ils
vont me réaliser en tant que coach
j'ai une responsabilité envers
mais je voulais faire plus
vivre des expériences je voulais
apporter une contribution plus grande et
dans la vie des gens
[Applaudissements]
je suis arrivé au canya le 16 juillet
19676 avant vendredi le lendemain matin
il y avait une compétition et un des
anciens professeurs m'a dit allons à
cette compétition allons voir courir les
élèves de Saint-Patrick
c'était la première fois de ma vie que
je m'étais les pieds sur une piste
d'athlétisme
[Applaudissements]
peut-être que si j'étais arrivé avec
déjà une expérience d'entraîneur la
tentation aurait été de leur dire les
gars je sais comment faire alors
qu'à l'inverse c'est moi qui a appris de
mes athlètes petit à petit j'ai
développé une approche africaine
de l'entraînement
[Musique]
je ne me vois pas comme d'un côté je
suis entraîneur puis je me change en
prêtre et ensuite en professeur
les trois font partie de ma vie et je me
présente aux jeunes gens comme une seule
et même personne
à des notes comme je ne suis pas venu
ici pour être entraîneur d'athlétisme ce
n'était pas du tout mon but premier
j'ai réussi à l'intégrer dans ma
conception de la vie et de mon travail
de missionnaire au Kenya
[Musique]
moi j'ai jamais eu l'âme d'un éducateur
tu vois je dis honnêtement moi je dis
j'avais l'âme d'entraîner d'aller
chercher quelque chose que la victoire
dans des grandes compétitions quand je
dis ça ça surprend mais moi je prends
comme ça quoi
il faut que la nana elle ait confiance
en toi
si croit pas vraiment ce que tu fais si
accroît pas en toi si toi tu dégages pas
quelque chose envers elle peut-être
compliqué là ça promet de revoir cet
effort
[Musique]
j'aimerais bien
ah c'est bien ça cet été j'avais une
fille qui a fait de l'eau libre c'est 10
km en eau libre et je lui ai mis des
séances très très dures et 16 x 50
éducatif comment on fait l'habitude
puissant tirer glisser l'épaule vers
l'avant là toujours les mêmes endules et
moins de coup de bras possible tu pars
toutes les minutes tu parles à Verdon
j'ai été des fois au bout je pensais que
je pouvais plus accélérer tu m'as fait
accélérer
traduit
je l'encourage beaucoup et là je vois
qu'il y a quand même des choses qui se
mettent en place il y a des déclics et
là là il y a des portes qui s'ouvrent tu
vois et ça c'est le genre de situation
que j'aime bien tu vois et après
n'oublie pas une chose tu t'es jamais
entraîné comme tu t'entraînes avant tu
portais sur un 10 km tu avais des
qualités tu avais tout ce qu'il fallait
mais donc quand tu plonges tu sais que
les filles d'à côté
ils font pas ce que tu fais à
l'entraînement en sachant que tu fais
partie des meilleurs nageuses au monde
en olive donc surtout regarde-moi
où tu peux faire une belle chose
d'accord quand je te dis ça moi je suis
sincère si je te dis je suis pas content
de toi je te le dis d'accord
je sais que tu es forte d'accord je sais
que tu es sérieux et j'aime t'entraîner
c'est une fille droite donc tu as tout
pour réussir et je crois en toi mais
surtout pense qu'à toi tu restes dans
ton truc à toi ok je t'appelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui s'entraîne avec Philippe Lucas qui
ont fait un écart immense sur le reste
des nageurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
faut parler franchement faut dire ce que
tu as sur le cœur aux athlètes
tu dis ce que tu vas faire avec eux et
tu dis ce qu'ils vont réussir
[Musique]
je l'aide de la même façon qu'il gagne
ou qu'il perdent
[Musique]
c'est pareil j'ai perdu mais ça ne va
pas me perturber pour la suite au
contraire ça va m'aider
[Musique]
j'essaie toujours de garder un juste
équilibre entre les hauts et les bas
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse tout
ramener à gagner ou perdre et si tu
penses ça tu risques d'être très déçu
parce que tu vas perdre bien plus
souvent que tu ne vas gagner
[Musique]
et alors l'objectif était de devenir
numéro 1 trouver qu'il n'était pas qu'un
joueur de terre battue et pouvoir gagner
Wimbledon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il aime la compétition le défi être en
concurrence avec le meilleur
[Applaudissements]
cette année-là la défaite fut très
douloureuse ça s'est joué en 5 7
dans le 5ème
[Applaudissements]
mais je vis quasiment le match avec la
même intensité
Raphaël était effondré et moi aussi
évidemment
[Musique]
il s'est mis à pleurer quand je les
rejoins au vestiaire
je lui ai dit qu'il ne fallait pas
pleurer qu'il avait fait un bon match il
m'a répondu je n'aurais peut-être plus
jamais l'occasion de gagner Wimbledon
alors je lui ai dit c'est une avoir à
nouveau c'est peut-être que tu ne
mérites pas il n'y a pas de raison de
pleurer c'est comme si je pleurais parce
que je n'avais pas une Rolls Royce
peut-être que je ne le mérite pas ce
qu'il faut faire c'est continuer
d'essayer
l'inspiration arrivera qu'elle me trouve
en train de travailler et c'est la
réalité dans cette vie ce qui dépend de
nous c'est le travail c'est tout ce
qu'on peut faire travailler et se battre
sans relâche
[Musique]
ce que je respecte le plus les gens qui
n'abandonnent jamais
et si tu as ce caractère
déterminé tenace obsédé par le boulot
bienfait c'est le caractère qu'il faut
[Applaudissements]
ça a été les 24 heures les plus
difficiles de ma carrière
[Applaudissements]
nous avions gagné 88% de nos matchs au
cours des quatre dernières années on
était numéro un mondial et on s'est fait
battre en quart de finale de la Coupe du
Monde par une très bonne équipe de
France
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu respectes les hommes qui ont essayé
de faire le travail même s'ils n'ont pas
réussi j'ai toujours eu un grand respect
pour eux je ne les ai jamais critiqué
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es face à 150 journalistes et 24
caméras de télévision
et tu dois parler de ton équipe et du
résultat
je ne peux pas m'excuser car c'est le
sport on gagne pas tous les coups
cette équipe a remporté 42 de ses 48
derniers matchs internationaux
on n'a pas gagné le plus important hier
mais comme je l'ai dit c'est le sport
[Musique]
les médias voulaient un changement
d'entraîneur car nous avions perdu la
Coupe du Monde tous les joueurs me
regardaient en se demandant est-ce qu'il
va rester ou est-ce qu'il va laisser
tomber
je devais rester
les joueurs ne voulaient pas de
changement
car il respectait le travail des coachs
je crois que la chose la plus précieuse
pour tous les coachs de haut niveau
c'est le respect des gens qui les
entraînent
ils ne veulent pas être aimé
ils ne veulent pas non plus être
détestés bataille ils veulent juste
qu'on les respecte pour leur travail
nous avons beaucoup appris de 2007 ce
qui nous a aidé en 2011
ça fait partie du sport mais aussi de la
vie de tous les jours
[Musique]
on apprend des situations difficiles et
ça nous aide à devenir meilleur
c'est juste une progression naturelle
[Musique]
plus en étant battu qu'en gagnant
j'ai vécu ça avec beaucoup de mes
athlètes y compris David Rudy chat
[Musique]
vous pouvez vous entraîner très dur et
ensuite réaliser une mauvaise
performance le jour de la compétition il
y a forcément un jour où vous serez déçu
vous apprendrez aussi de vous défaites
voilà un bel exemple d'apprentissage la
première fois que David a participé à
une compétition il n'a pas gagné mais ce
n'était pas la fin ça n'était que le
début
si vous demandez à David qu'elle a été
le moment décisif de sa carrière il vous
répondra certainement sa défaite en 2009
c'était la première fois qu'il
représente le Kenya dans une grande
compétition internationale
il y avait beaucoup d'attentes autour de
lui
c'est un Massaï il portait donc les
espoirs de son ethnie mais aussi du pays
il avait vraiment énormément de pression
sur les épaules
[Applaudissements]
il s'est fait éliminer de très peu en
demi-finales d'un centième de seconde
[Musique]
il ne sait pas qualifié pour la finale
juste après la course pour lui dire
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
une grosse erreur tactique
à ce moment-là immédiatement après la
course l'athlète et c'est déjà de gérer
sa déception personnelle
[Musique]
la dernière personne qu'il veut entendre
lui rappeler ses erreurs c'est son coach
laisse un peu d'espace donne du temps ça
peut prendre des jours peut-être des
semaines
laisse le s’ouvrir laisse-lui te dire
j'ai vraiment fait une grosse erreur
dans cette course
est prête à recevoir de la compassion du
soutien
j'ai encore jeune
maintenant c'est vraiment l'année
prochaine que nous devons penser
moi je passe mais toi non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Jeux olympiques d'Athènes en 2004 nos
résultats n'avaient pas été bon
chaud dans la j'ai donc été évincé
trop singulière
[Musique]
étudier 6 mois à l'école du parti
le bureau général a décidé de me
réintégrer pour préparer les Jeux de
Pékin
[Musique]
j'étais capable d'obtenir tu dois sauver
c'est pas très dur d'entraîner c'est dur
mais bon c'est pas le plus dur le plus
dur c'est de gérer l'humain c'est ça le
plus dur l'humain c'est très complexe et
puis surtout ça pardonne rien quoi rien
du tout
capable d'envoyer alors quand tu prends
tes affaires tu rentres chez toi
le corps on peut toujours le mesurer
mais notre plus gros challenge c'est le
mental
après 2007 je suis devenu à fanatique
j'étais totalement obsédé par mon
objectif
être le meilleur coach possible et que
mon équipe soit la meilleure possible
j'ai parfois été trop dur avec Raphaël
mais je crois qu'il a toujours su que ce
que je faisais je faisais pour lui pas
pour moi
[Musique]
pas un objectif c'est un chemin pour y
arriver
je pose de la défaite à Wimbledon on a
compris qu'il fallait faire quelque
chose de plus
[Musique]
le problème est qu'on était arrivé sur
le circuit trop jeune à 16 ans
on devait affronter des gens plus forts
plus grands donc la seule façon de s'en
sortir était de jouer très haut avec pas
mal d'effets
et de se battre sur toutes les balles
et ça lui a permis de gagner
l'idée a donc été de changer cette
habitude
pour essayer d'être plus agressif
dans les échanges
c'est ce qu'on a essayé de mettre en
place en 2008
[Musique]
en tant que coach quand tes athlètes
sont au sommet après une performance
incroyable
c'est à toi de les ramener sur terre
et quand ils sont au plus bas après une
défaite c'est à toi de les relever
quand tu viens sur mon terrain je veux
que tu te sentes chez toi à l'abri ici
c'est ton espace secret
[Applaudissements]
et c'est un endroit où tu peux juste
être toi-même
si vous voulez être les meilleurs dans
votre sport vous devez aussi être fort
mentalement ça parle de l'esprit les
jambes s'occuperont de courir mais le
moteur c'est la tête en vous perdez
repensez à comment vous vous êtes
entraînés il faut réfléchir pourquoi
est-ce que j'ai perdu qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé on apprend beaucoup quand on
se remet en question
[Musique]
sa défaite il faut qu'on se penche sur
ma tactique
je dois sérieusement la revoir
une des choses que l'on a apprises avec
cette défaite c'est qu'il avait tendance
à rester au milieu du peloton
final
et ce fut la dernière course de David
rudicha à l'arrière ou au milieu du
peloton à partir de ce jour-là toutes
ces courses il les a couru en tête
après 2007 on a beaucoup travaillé sur
la psychologie
biologie du cerveau
force mentale
gestion de la pression
une des réflexions c'était de comprendre
que l'imprévu se produit toujours
parce qu'en quart de finale en 2016
l'imprévu s'était produit et nous
n'avions pas su nous adapter
oui on a donc compris que face à
l'imprévu on devait se préparer
mentalement
et ça fait partie de notre stratégie
pour 2011 quoi qu'il se passe on sera
prêt à le gérer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les All Blacks n'avait pas gagné la
Coupe du Monde depuis 24 ans
[Musique]
était énorme
et une fois encore nous sommes arrivés à
la coupe du monde 2011 classée numéro 1
mondiale
mais on sait qu'il y a une grande
différence entre être le numéro un
mondial et être champion du monde
[Musique]
c'était lors d'un entraînement à
Wellington
je suis entré dans les vestiaires et
j'ai dit aux garçons
l'imprévu est arrivé les gars et on va
le surmonter
[Musique]
était probablement le meilleur joueur du
monde en 2011
au sommet de sa carrière il marquait en
moyenne 20 points par match pour les All
Blacks
il était capable de buter de diriger
l'équipe c'était vraiment notre pièce
maîtresse
évidemment tu es inquiet lorsqu'ils ne
joue pas
mais on ne pouvait rien y faire à part
aller de l'avant et se remettre au
boulot
[Musique]
de jeu remplaçant on savait qu'il allait
se mettre en quatre pour l'équipe et
pour Dan Carter
[Musique]
c'est lui aussi blessé
au cours de la préparation des Jeux
Olympiques de Pékin la tension était
extrême
tes mains sont trop écartées
[Musique]
on ne peut pas espérer réaliser de
grandes performances
très bien tu sais faire ce mouvement
maintenant
[Applaudissements]
tous les soirs allongé sur mon lit je
réfléchissais
comment corriger les problèmes que
j'avais vu ce jour-là afin que les
athlètes s'améliorent dans les plus
brefs délais
ne cherchez pas à contrôler la vitesse
[Musique]
l'équipe féminine a donné satisfaction
les progrès sont importants et vous ne
devez pas penser que votre sélection est
acquise pour autant à la fin de chaque
compétition tout recommence à zéro
c'est comme ça qu'on peut composer la
meilleure équipe pour les JO
j'ai 20 joueurs sous la main
aux Jeux olympiques en a droit à 14
joueurs plus un joker
[Musique]
Bouddha
surhumains et fort animal par moment
matin tu descends pour annoncer l'équipe
qui va partir aux Jeux Olympiques
étudie quatre d'entre eux ou à 5 d'entre
eux l'histoire est terminée pour vous
pour rentrer chez vous on va finir sans
vous
ça c'est des moments douloureux même
très douloureux
[Musique]
je pense que William espérer être dans
le groupe de 14 à 7 minutes là il me est
donc je lui dis écoute tu es
véritablement quelqu'un que je peux
imaginer comme joker Deluxe
susceptible de rentrer dans les deux
trois derniers matchs de la compétition
au moment où tout se joue donc tu vas
d'une certaine façon être en plus et si
tu t'investis pas dans ce rôle tu vas
finir par décrocher et tu rentreras
jamais
le préparateur physique me tient informé
et me dit de plus en plus de dingue et
de plus en plus près à la fin des jeux
il était prêt même pour faire les
épreuves d'haltérophilie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le quart de finale c'est le moment
déterminant des jeux
[Musique]
je vous l'Espagne qui est
potentiellement vainqueur des Jeux
Olympiques
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
elle est solide elle prend confiance
[Musique]
ils nous domine sur le début de match
mais même de manière presque outrancière
on est à 5 simuler hier
[Musique]
ouais là tu te dis bon mais si on a
besoin d'un joker c'est peut-être
maintenant parce que si on perd celui-là
de toute manière le Joker il servira
plus grand chose
donc à l'habitant je dis bon écoute tu
rentres et
telle qu'on se les promis
deuxième mi-temps exceptionnel il fait 7
tirs cette nuit
il réussit tout autour de manière
insolente
lui tout seul il fait exploser l'équipe
d'Espagne
on remet en selle parce qu'il nous remet
en confiance il nous remet en réussite
et l'histoire est belle jusqu'au bout
parce que on est à match nul à 10
secondes de la fin
[Applaudissements]
Karabatic pragnant tir pour essayer de
faire la décision
le gardien adverse repousse la balle et
qui se retrouve là
on sait même pas pourquoi parce que
c'est vraiment pas à la place où il
aurait dû être
[Musique]
tu te dis mais pourquoi ça me revient
dans les mains ça aurait pu partir
n'importe où et ça c'est encore sur lui
que ça tombe
à tous les Espagnols qui tombent qui
s'efforent dans ce terrain
à ce moment-là
il est béni quoi il est béni je sais pas
de qui mais il est béni
[Musique]
il a tout d'un coup en quelques minutes
le niveau de lumière et de récompense
qu'il s'est gagné dans son parcours je
dirais isolé de courage
tu te dis [__] c'est un coup génial
qui force le respect ont il y a
tellement d'autres coups qu'on a qu'on a
pas un séjour et qu'on n'a pas réussi
que de temps en temps il faut prendre de
la distance avec tout ça
[Musique]
la compétition arrive t'attends que ça
depuis des mois
[Applaudissements]
tu es seul dans un stade de 80 000
personnes
si tu veux gagner une médaille de
olympique tu ne peux pas te permettre la
moindre erreur
ce serait le plus beau métier du monde
s'il n'y avait pas les matchs
[Musique]
on te demande pas moins que d'aller
gagner les Jeux Olympiques te dire après
il y a rien d'autre quoi
tu sais que ce point-là est crucial
et tout le monde stress
c'est naturel c'est une stresses pas
c'est qu'il y a un problème
[Applaudissements]
on avait décidé de changer les choses
c'est ce qu'on a fait en 2008
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le match était quasiment gagné par
Raphaël
la tension la tension était irrespirable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
de perdre le 5ème 7 ce qui aurait été
une catastrophe pour nous
mais la vérité c'est qu'à ce moment-là
c'était difficile de ne rien dire parce
que la situation était vraiment tendue
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je viens d'une génération où la
discrétion prime avant tout
ces émotions
de ne pas montrer plus que ce qui est
nécessaire
les émotions ressortent évidemment
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au final au final c'est une émotion
partagée
[Musique]
je peux dire que je suis reconnaissant
envers la vie car la vie nous a très
bien traité
au bout du compte un entraîneur
dans mon cas en tout cas ce qui me
plairait réellement c'est de voir que je
peux aider la personne donc forcément
qu'elle gagne mais que je puisse l'aider
à gagner à devenir une meilleure
personne et à affronter les situations
difficiles de la bonne manière
la une application l'application que
j'ai moi avec Raphaël n'est pas la même
que celle d'un entraîneur qui est
aujourd'hui avec un joueur et demain
avec un autre
pour moi c'est un lien affectif
[Musique]
on était fait pour être ensemble pour
travailler ensemble pour pour réussir
ensemble on était fait comme ça son
caractère mon caractère on était fait
pour
[Musique]
lors c'était bon c'était comme ma fille
il y avait une relation forte qui s'est
créée quoi bien sûr j'ai eu à 14 ans et
demi habité avec moi j'ai travaillé 6
ans avec elle et je l'ai côtoyé en tant
que humain pendant six années
quand tu diriges un athlète de cette
dimension 6 ans c'est long
lors elle n'aimait pas l'entraînement
mais elle aimait la compétition donc tu
la préparer comme si c'était une
compétitions
[Musique]
toujours un petit mot gentil un petit
challenge un petit McDo toi l'été jeunes
t'inquiète pas je l'emmenais comme ça et
il y a des moments elle a fait des trucs
attention elle a pas enfiler les perles
elle faisait des trucs mais il fallait
la mettre dans cette conception de la
compétition qui se passe à
l'entraînement
alors c'était une fille qui changeait de
comportement une semaine avant la
compète c'était plus la même ça devenait
un faux un peu rien à voir avec la fille
une semaine avant
[Applaudissements]
vous savez qu'elle était bien qu'elle
est en forme tu es fort tes confiant
mais surtout c'est que les sautes ils
savent tu vas être dur à battre
donc tu peux faire n'importe quoi
l'échauffement et la durée 4 minutes ça
sert à rien de le faire plus avec elle
fallait la mettre dans l'eau tu la
trempe à sortir
tu dis voilà aujourd'hui c'est
maintenant c'est tout de suite c'est là
qu'il faut être bon
[Applaudissements]
je disais tout le monde va mal ça va
brûler pour tout le monde
mais toi tu l'as vécu 50000 fois ça tu
vas passer au-dessus de la douleur tu en
as rien à [__] si ça brûle tu accélère
encore c'est toi qui domine la douleur
tu l'as domines à domine pas
sur ces trois temps suivant
c'est la première fois qu'une Française
est championne olympique
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quand on gagne le travail a été fait
chez moi
[Applaudissements]
ma place est en amont
c'est un peu comme si j'étais là pour
cuisiner mais pas pour déguster
pour semer mais pas pour récolter
[Applaudissements]
as peut-être plus jamais sur la ligne de
départ d'une finale olympique
tu ne peux pas te permettre la moindre
erreur il y a plus de place pour
l'improvisation on fait exactement ce
que tu sais faire là où tu es bon tu es
en confiance
[Applaudissements]
du coup de starter jusqu'à la ligne
d'arrivée tu fonces
pour essayer de penser à autre chose
l'oeil rivait sur ma montre en attendant
20h ce soir là
j'ai essayé aussi d'imaginer qu'est-ce
qui se passe dans sa tête
comment gère-t-il ça
est-ce qu'il arrive à garder son calme
et sa concentration habituelle
rend mon Dieu je commence à douter je ne
sais pas comment ça va se passer
[Applaudissements]
je me projetais comme ça avec lui notre
seul dénominateur commun c'était Dieu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pouvais l'atteindre et lui pouvait
atteindre David notre seul contact était
spirituel à travers la prière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je n'aurais jamais pensé vivre un jour
un moment comme ça un de mes athlètes
était champion olympique et regarde man
du monde tout dans la même soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour un événement aussi important l'État
et le peuple chinois voulait qu'on
démontre notre force
on s'est préparé pour les JO comment se
préparer à la guerre
[Musique]
sur 8 épreuves mes athlètes ont rapporté
7 médailles d'or
l'histoire
les Jeux olympiques de 2008 ont été la
récompense la plus importante de ma vie
[Musique]
pendant le match l'entraîneur est un
homme seul enfermé dans ses pensées
j'ai passé tellement de nuit s'endormir
à réfléchir aux décisions à prendre
parce qu'il faut gérer la pression qui
vient du Club de la Presse des
supporters des joueurs
[Applaudissements]
il est indispensable de savoir garder la
tête froide
et le fait que j'ai un caractère plutôt
tranquille que j'aime parler et
réfléchir pour trouver des solutions ça
doit certainement beaucoup m'aider
[Musique]
je prends le stress comme une chose
positive car c'est le carburant pour
bien faire notre travail souvent on n'a
pas le temps de penser aux conséquences
d'un échec
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
0 pour la petite commode après 36
minutes dans cette première période
j'essaie de toujours garder une attitude
positive même si le match ne se passe
pas comme prévu
un entraîneur doit accepter qu'il ne
peut pas tout contrôler
[Musique]
que les choses tournent bien ou mal
le jeu depuis le banc de touche est très
compliqué
de toute façon ils sont concentrés et ne
t'entendent pas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
qu'une question de parole ça passe aussi
par un langage corporel
[Musique]
encore une fois pour les hommes
d'Ancelotti j'ai toujours gardé une
grande confiance pendant la finale
contre l'Atletico parce que jusqu'à la
dernière seconde les joueurs n'ont pas
baissé les bras tout pouvait encore
arriver
[Musique]
par Lucas modrić
extraordinaire
[Musique]
elle balle delco la beauté du football
c'est la prévisibilité ce n'est jamais
fini et ça rend le jeu passionnant parce
que ce n'est pas toujours le meilleur
qui gagne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au final pour moi ça reste un jeu et je
fais tout pour qu'il soit le plus
divertissant possible
[Musique]
c'est terminé la dixième Elena elle est
dans les bras de 40 chez loti
pour moi le foot est resté la même chose
que lorsque j'ai commencé à jouer à
l'âge de 10 ans une passion un amusement
le jour où je ne pense plus comme ça
j'arrête et j'irai faire autre chose
[Musique]
bon entraîneur c'est quelqu'un qui ne
dort plus
ou compétition je vais dormir 3 heures
par nuit mais pas parce que j'ai peur
parce que mon cerveau est un ébullition
c'est une cocotte-minute le village
olympique c'est un endroit où ça sent le
stress du matin au soir
tous les gens qui sont là sont là pour
réaliser une performance extrême avec
toutes les déceptions le peu de joie
parce qu'il y a quand même un peu d'élus
au fur et à mesure que l'on construit ce
parcours vers le titre olympique
autour de nous monte cette pression
des Français
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
exceptionnels de l'équipe de France de
bravo
[Musique]
non pas l'exceptionnel mais au rationnel
l'analyse du jeu l'adversaire comment va
le jouer comment on va gagner ces duels
tu es tellement dans ce désir
d'anticiper que là où tu es tu vis pas
le moment
mon épouse qui m'appelait tous les soirs
la Pékin ce moment de téléphone où elle
me parlait de mes enfants mes amis de la
famille mais t'étais insupportable parce
que j'avais le sentiment que ça
m'éloignait de mon équipe et de mon
objectif
quand tu t'en rend compte au bout d'un
moment tu te dis mais qu'est-ce que tu
es monstre
[Musique]
la première finale olympique de l'équipe
de France de handball et c'est parti
pour ce moment historique
sur la prochaine attaque on fait
espagnol renversé
[Musique]
faut vite lever le bras ils étaient déjà
à la limite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
championne olympique en balle au moment
où on est champion olympique je vois
tous mes joueurs qui s'embrassent et qui
pleure je vois dans les tribunes les
familles les supporters cette
embrasement des larmes partout
et moi je suis glacial
je suis encore en train de me dire
qu'est-ce qu'il faudra faire dans une
heure demain
et je crois que j'en ai souffert c'est à
dire son malin je me dis mais tu es fou
quoi tu t'es en train de vivre peut-être
ton plus beau moment d'entraîneur celui
dont tu rêves depuis toujours il était
pas capable d'en profiter
[Musique]
je m'étais tellement construit dans ce
rôle de celui qui était né les émotions
que j'ai fini par complètement être dans
la mienne
[Musique]
le premier moment d'émotion je le
perçois au moment où on rentre en France
toute la nuit je vais lire des messages
de gens remerciant l'équipe pour des
moments d'exception pour des moments où
ils ont été chaviré des moments où ils
ont cru qu'ils allaient mourir
dans la vie déjà il y a peu de choses
qui font un chavirer comme ça il y a peu
de moments de cette intensité là
l'animation du sport on l'aperçoit quand
on la partage avec le plus grand nombre
[Applaudissements]
tout d'un coup je prends la mesure de ce
que l'on vient de réaliser
[Musique]
tout le monde stress c'est naturel mais
si tu ne stresses pas c'est qu'il y a un
problème
en tant que coach je me suis amélioré en
vieillissant et j'ai appris à gérer
cette pression
au niveau international c'est d'abord
une question de construction
les joueurs n'ont pas besoin qu'un petit
gars comme moi viennent leur parler deux
heures avant le match
les instructions ont déjà tout été
données ils sont prêts
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si on ne gagnait pas ce match
[Applaudissements]
Thierry du sautoir et son équipe ont
joué un rugby exceptionnel
nous étions en difficulté
ils ont certainement été meilleur que
nous sur ce match
[Applaudissements]
tu es assis dans le box des entraîneurs
et tu te dis qu'est-ce qui va se passer
si nous perdons ce match
et là je me suis vu caché dans le sud de
la France avec béret moustache barbe
très bel endroit le sud de la France
mais sans ma femme sans mes enfants
[Applaudissements]
ok oui nous avions eu trois blessures au
même poste
mais c'est la réalité tu dois juste
avancer et faire ton boulot
ton Steve Donald est entré comme
quatrième meneur de jeu il n'avait plus
joué pour les All Blacks depuis 24 mois
je ne lui rien dit
il n'y a rien à dire dans un tel moment
il savait que nous étions tous derrière
lui
l'équipe l'accueilli sur le terrain pour
bien lui faire sentir qu'il en faisait
partie
[Musique]
tu penses toujours positif
je me disais qu'il était capable de
faire le boulot
et il l'a fait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est passé du gars qui n'a jamais très
bien joué avec les All Blacks et qui
n'étaient plus dans l'équipe depuis deux
ans au statut de héros national
incroyable
[Applaudissements]
le soulagement
la paix que j'ai ressenti après tout ça
c'était juste fantastique
je ne supportant pas un homme émotif
mais quand j'ai vu ma femme sur le
terrain avec ce grand sourire
c'était très très émouvant
quel moment
[Musique]
je fais partie de ça j'ai été entraîneur
pendant plus de 40 ans j'ai entraîné 8
dans les All Blacks j'ai coaché plus de
130 tests matchs et là c'était la fin
c'était l'apogée
gagner contre les Français encore eux
à 8,7 une immense victoire 8 7
un petit point d'écart mais un point ça
peut changer la vie des gens
[Musique]
je suis fier d'avoir gagné tout ce que
l'on a gagné mais je suis avant tout
fier de l'avoir gagné avec des gens bien
j'ai fait du mieux que j'ai pu
et je laisse maintenant Dieu seul juge
de ce que j'aurais pu mieux faire
moi le dimanche quand j'ai rien à faire
je suis content de rentrer dès le lundi
je te le dis j'ai besoin de ça bien sûr
que c'est une drogue
[Musique]